[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen meine torten
weltweite gibt es ein weiteres plätzchen
rezept und zwar dass mond plätzchen
rezept und ihr könnt sie auch mit
collagen oder mohn augen denn wenn ihr
wollt sind nämlich in der mitte mit
johannisbeeren ballade gefüllt und die
manchmal macht die plätzchen so richtig
fruchtig und die plätzchen sind auch
sehr weich und schmecken richtig gut und
die zutaten dazu stelle ich euch jetzt
kurz vor
für den teig braucht ihr 150 gramm
butter 100 gramm ohne 200 gramm mehl 80
gramm puderzucker ein eigelb und ein
paar grohmann in zucker oder ein
esslöffel selbstgemachten vanillezucker
und der mond da muss es noch gemahlen
werden und das mache ich schnell im
thermomix ihr könnt es in jeder anderen
küchenmaschine machen und das mache ich
jetzt bei stufe 10 etwa 20 sekunden
und so sieht jetzt der fertig gemahlen
mohn aus und da kommen jetzt alle
anderen zutaten mit dazu also auch wenig
den jetzt von hand kneten wollt einfach
alle zutaten jetzt miteinander verkneten
und die zutaten sollten auch hier alle
zimmertemperatur haben dann mache ich
jetzt 40 sekunden auf stufe vier
unter teilige teig kommt jetzt für
mindestens drei stunden in den
kühlschrank ich lasse ihn jetzt aber
über nach dem kühlschrank
nach der schulzeit zeige ich euch wie
man jetzt die plätzchen herstellt und
bei mir sind die plätzchen alle gleich
groß
falls ihr das aber nicht so exakt machen
wollt könnt ihr euch auch einfach
teigstücke vom ganzen tag abreißen und
die zu kugeln formen
aber ich finde es geht eigentlich ganz
schnell mit der teig rolle und so habt
ihr wirklich ganz perfekte gleichmäßige
platzieren
der teig für die mohn plätzchen sitzt
erkannt wenn ihr den einer nach dem
kühlschrank hat müsst ihr denn ganz kurz
weich kneten aber wirklich nur kurz
sodass er noch kalt bleibt jetzt
halbierte ihr den am besten und formt
euch eine rolle
[Musik]
die rolle die hat einen durchmesser von
da schneidet mal das anfangs stück und
schneide mir dann etwa 2 cm breite
stücke
und diese frau mittels zu kugeln
[Musik]
wenn es bei euch so zwischen den händen
nicht klappt nehmt ihr einen teig stück
und könnt auch auf der arbeitsfläche
rollen
die plätzchen werden dann etwas flach
gedrückt
und so setzt ist die dann auf ein
vorbereitetes backblech
[Musik]
in die plätzchen kommt jetzt noch eine
vertiefung in die mitte die könnt ihr
mit dem finger eindrücken aber ich finde
es besser wenn er das mit einem
kochlöffel macht mit dem ende dieser ist
jetzt etwas klein aber ich habe auch ein
anderes wissen und zwar habe ich in
meiner box schublade auch immer so
abspritzen erste hilfe koffer oder sowas
und da nehme ich jetzt dieses ende und
drückt das in die plätzchen ein noch ein
bisschen tiefer sondern halben
zentimeter tief ungefähr
[Musik]
die flächen müssen damit für etwas zehn
minuten bei 180° gebacken werden oder
muss darauf achten dass sie vorher
richtig schön kalt sind falls sie zu
warm geworden sind durch das kneten und
durch das rollen stellte sie lieber noch
mal eine halbe stunde in den kühlschrank
ist es nämlich so dass viele plätzchen
ihre form behalten und wenn der teig
aber zu weit war verlieren sie ganz
schnell ihre vor und es geht natürlich
für alle plätzchen die ihr aus mürbeteig
erstellt denn dieser hat einen sehr
hohen butter oder fettgehalt und nach
dem backen müsst ihr die plätzchen gut
auskühlen lassen
am besten geht es natürlich wie immer
auf einem kuchen rost und danach werden
sie dann gefüllt
ich nehme für die plätzchen jetzt
johannes sammer milliarde schwarze
johannisbeere und die möchte ich jetzt
in einem kleinen topf auf dem herd
erwärmen und dann mit einem kleinen
spritzbeutel in die vertiefungen
einführen
wenn die marmelade so kurz vorm kochen
ist nämlich sehr vom herd runter und ich
möchte doch keine stückchen drin
deswegen gebe ich sie noch durch einen
sieg oder ihr könnt auch direkt schelin
nehmen
[Musik]
die marmelade kommen jetzt in eine
einwegspritze beute und sehen sich hier
über eine klar sind so habe ich dann
beide hände frei und kann die marmelade
hier einführen ohne das nicht kleckern
die tüte verschließe ich jetzt irgendwo
und nun kommt jetzt ein kleines loch
rein und durch dieses loch kommt jetzt
die marmelade in die öffnungen
[Musik]
jetzt müsst ihr wenn die mama nadi noch
heiß ist den puderzucker drüber
schreiben denn so schmilzt der
puderzucker über der marmelade und nur
da teig außen rum ist weiß
und so sehen dann die fertigen plätzchen
aus die marinade muss jetzt noch
abkühlen und west werden und danach
könnt ihr die plätzchen in einer
keksdose aufbewahren am besten schichtet
er etwas backpapier zwischen rheydt
damit sie nicht aneinander kleben und
sie werden mit der zeit immer weiter und
schmeckt wirklich sehr gut
[Musik]
ich wünsche euch viel spaß beim
nachbacken und bis zum nächsten mal
[Musik]